just a hop skip and a jump away from
Berlin lies a wonder to behold spreewald
Germany spreewald is comprised of vast
waterways UNESCO protected forests and
lastly and perhaps most importantly
spreewald is known for a salty snack the
world-renowned spreewald gherkin this
great big story was made possible by the
German National Tourist Board and Hans
Zimmer core travel insurance it's no
secret that gherkins are part of the
culture here and everyone wants to talk
about it
their common names private the common
here in later in Slovak and quizzes the
other diabolos in my name is Colin stoic
healthy common boy wait did you just say
Museum of gherkins tell me more
ksama Stan after many people did the
squirt museum this one's a mine size you
want the most
therefore even that filthy gardening
captain after been preserved
Ellis people wouldn't not yeah I defense
are easy as in so let me and then or
you're not going I wouldn't know hold
your gherkins Carl it's actually time
for us to go and explore more of
spreewald by boat
I mean punt explore more of spreewald by
punt
my name is Montfort an open can follow
can Feynman in schism cutest Ellison
fear not Philomena visage father owned
the visage causing the famine sayin only
fear fear not fulfill middle ETSU at
Vienna million gesture to zoo and
inspire in me are much marketers Sean I
am as a leap Afton Karthikeya okay cool
but what about the gherkins can you take
us to the gherkins
yeah gamma D Gordy's intense trick
lightens up quick to a minor lipping
skorca does us the Dorothy Jernigan oh
my god did I forget to mention there was
a gherkin Queen thanks for the reminder
Manfred we've got to go meet her yeah
hello has been busy beers it's been a
I'm keeping the super Copenhagen and
what exactly does that mean when the
presentation favorite only stats a
personal test now button mess me want
the most monitors of Salman
workin on communicating on your favorite
so oh I have a question what's your
favorite gherkin
mana dipping schoolkids dissolver guca
suddenly I'm in the mood for
[Music]